[Musik]
ach du heilige scheiße tiffany was essen
wir denn dazu geschickt
elektrosmog und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video und ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut mir auch denn
heute steht ein wirklich sehr sehr
interessantes video an
wir machen heute den ersten paar davon
ich bin gespannt wie viele parks ist am
ende werden also ich gehe davon zwei aus
ganz eventuell 23 mal ganz kurz diese
konzeptidee oder vielleicht auch format
idee erklären
ich will mich immer so beobachtet wenn
ich hier nicht die jalousien runter
woche deswegen also wundert euch nicht
über dieses komische hintergrundgeräusch
jetzt gerade auf jeden fall ist diesem
freitag am 29 november es ist ja 29
glaubt schon mal wieder black friday das
heißt über gibt es reduzierte sachen vor
allem online und so und ich habe mir
folgendes gedacht weil ich immer so
viele unboxing videos machen china
schrott kram alles mögliche was er
schreibt und was mir selber einen kopf
kommt viel ja in letzter zeit auch so
mit kopfhörern und irgendwelche gadgets
halt und weil ich halt diese ganzen
unboxing videos mache muss ich sagen
bekomme ich täglich will dich täglich
mehrere mails meistens sogar 10 20 30
mails am tag von irgendwelchen amazon
resellern irgendwelchen china händlern
irgendwelchen europäischen händlern auf
also leute die halt im internet
irgendwas weiterverkaufen wollen ihr
eigenes produkt verkaufen wollen
dropshipping machen wollen und sonstwas
und mehrheit anbieten wir geben wir
ihnen kostenlos produktstärke doch mal
vor das problem ist das meiste davon ist
wirklich kompletter müll und das sind
sehr unseriöse kontakte manchmal auch es
gibt allerdings auch coole sachen dabei
und alle sachen die ich halbwegs cool
fand den habe ich meine adresse zukommen
lassen und die haben wir ein paket
geschickt mit irgendwas drin ich zeige
euch mal kurz die ganzen pakete die wir
heute haben
das ist auch schon das größte ich habe
keinen plan was da drin ist
das problem jetzt ihr seht welch
vielleicht gar nicht mehr so belasten
dass erst mal dabei ist sind allerdings
nicht alle weil ihr müsst mich auch noch
sie auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt den
letzten zwei wochen wirklich ein paar
produkt bekommen auch große sachen
anscheinend und deswegen gibt es heute
diese sechs freude unboxing video reihe
hat passend zum black friday in der wir
diese ganzen sachen auspacken
ich bekomme für nichts davon geld ich
mache das alles kostenlos auch gerade
aus diesem grund bei dieser händler
meisten zeit kein budget haben für
irgendwie sonneberg facebook oder so
vieles davon ist auch leider meistens
hier sehr unseriös ich kann ich ja immer
so eine mail ein band wie sie dann
manchmal aussieht dann schreibt dass so
jemand heim reseller in deutsche
amazonas also wirklich wegen amazon.com
da irgendwie google übersetzer
chinesisch auf deutsch amazonas raus
will schon sehr oft gelesen ganz
verrückt zum teil habe genug gelabert
gestartet ist einfach wahr und ich bin
total gespannt vielleicht wenn ich
irgendwas davon richtig gut gebrauchen
was ich aber trotzdem noch kurz sagen
sollte ich hoffe ich finde alle adressen
von diesen leuten die mir etwas
geschickt habe auch in meinem ganzen
mails wieder damit ich euch das in der
beschreibung verlinkt weil das kann ja
sein dass jemand von euch da interesse
hat und irgendwann produkt und ich will
mir auch ziemlich sicher dass die
meisten händler jedoch sehr aufregende
trader so angeschrieben da auch rabatte
haben und so das wäre geschickter gerne
vorbei dann starten wir mit dem ersten
produkt weiter ich bin heftig gespannt
[Musik]
eine drohne geil
wir haben hier eine drohne lm 0 1 okay
hier oben stehen schon einige sachen
raum kann euch das hier sehr gern mal in
die kamera halten ich hoffe ihr könnt
das lesen wir haben heute leider keine
juli dabei da schläft schon
wir haben schon ziemlich spät muss ich
sagen wir uns schon nach 1 uhr also eine
drohne eine flugdrohne die kann bei foto
video position halten geistigen erkennen
sich alter die kamera-autos what the
[ __ ] automatischen follower also an sich
wirklich wohl eine drohne die einiges
kann ich habe selber eine magic
die kostet 2000 euro und ist wirklich
ein heißes ding so habe ich schon auch
cool auf damit gemacht ich könnte jetzt
gleich eigentlich mal gucken was das
ding hier dann wert ist man muss
zumindest schon mal sagen es ist
ziemlich leicht
st
das ist einmal die flugdrohne hier haben
wir noch ein paar rotoren das ist einmal
cool wenn ihr dabei sind weil wenn man
mal aus versehen eine baumkrone frisiert
dann sollte man die wechseln wenn die
leicht beschädigt sind
kennt ihr dieses da kriegt man so
gantzer oder wenn die person oberfläche
geht es bei mir zumindest so ja das hier
ist dann wahrscheinlich der akku ist
dass der akku sollte dafür seien hier
vorne haben wir eine kamera drin
und hier kann man die dann an machen ja
man wird schon funktionieren dann haben
sie hier die fernsteuerung und ich muss
mal schauen also das ist schon mal das
erste ding ich kann jetzt leider hier
nicht testen aber ich werde euch
vermutlich jetzt gleich kurze sequenz
einbänden vielleicht auch eine ausnahme
hiervon wie ich dir in die luft schicken
um euch dann zu sagen ob das ding was
taugt also auf jeden fall eigentlich
schon mal da ist ach so und was mir
gerade auch ein feld leute wir sind kurz
vor den eine millionen abonnenten hier
auf youtube deswegen wirklich super
freuen wenn ihr alle den kanal abonniert
weil ich die ganzen produkte auch
natürlich verlosen werden als ich werde
mich selber behalten die sind coole
sachen bei wahrscheinlich dann die immer
auf instagram da heißt ja alex wie das
könnt ihr auch sehr gern abchecken auf
jeden fall erstmal danke für die drohnen
ich wollte noch ganz kurz schauen wie
teuer werden ist oder was das ding okay
leute ich habe jetzt mal versucht alles
einzustellen und ich hoffe im besten
fall funktioniert das jetzt einfach
deswegen schauen wir mal
ich habe hier übrigens schon eine drohne
starten lassen gibt sogar ein speed
modus hier
ich mache mal direkt im speed modus an
also fliegt auf jeden fall ganz gut was
schon schlechtere drohen
mal gucken wie hoch die geht also es ist
schon die maximale ich will man sagen so
50 metern und da vielleicht ein bisschen
höher so gar nicht war nicht mal nicht
mal 50 und ich kann euch immer kurz dem
foto einwänden was mit der dann
geschossen wurde damit ihr die qualität
seht also an sich um ein bisschen spaß
zu haben lohnt sich das auf jeden fall
wenn man jetzt allerdings auch gute
videos unsere damit machen möchte ich
weiß nicht ob die 100 euro da richtig
investiert sind trotzdem dank für das
produkt verlor sich natürlich auch auf
instagram okay ihr habt ihr denn heute
schon die aufnahme gesehen ich habe es
gerade abgesteckt die kostet 99 euro auf
amazon alles nichts mega krasses aber
ich habe euch wahrscheinlich schon
gesagt ob das ding was taugt oder nicht
trotzdem noch nicht so für einsteiger
ist das ein cooles modell gut dann hatte
ich das mal wieder ein
du kannst wieder ausgehen genau danke
gut erstes produkt haben wir hinter uns
machen weiter ich würde mal sagen frauen
mit dem hier noch nicht mal was machen
wir mit weiter da habe ich wirklich
überhaupt keine ahnung was das sein
könnte
ok jetzt gleich explodiert
wahrscheinlich das ist auf jeden fall
nicht so meins verpackt legen wir auch
schon ein bisschen halb aufgegangen
hatte vermutlich eine lange reise hinter
sich aber gut wir schauen mal was das
hier also das ist gerade schon wie so
eine vorweihnachtszeit für mich man kann
irgendwas auspacken und weiß nicht was
drin ist okay
es ist das denn alter airportpark am
boden case for airports
ich halte euch das hier auch mal kurz in
die kamera oder ich bin es so noch mal
ein gleich eine karbon hülle für
airports mit powerpoint ach so ja also
wir haben hier ein produkt eingepackt
auf jeden fall wie ein iphone kann man
hier direkt schon sehen was airports
laden kann also eine power bank für
airports praktisch wobei ich mich da
jetzt frage man kann ja eigentlich seine
airports auch so an der paar bänken
anschließend gut aber man hat dann
keinen carbon case dabei noch mal dass
man auch kummer es ist auf jeden fall
wirklich sehr hochwertig eingepackt muss
ich sagen gefällt mir schon mal sehr gut
ja und die haben wir dann ein mini usb
kabel oder usb-kabel ich habe keine
ahnung ich komme mir den ganzen körper
so durcheinander
auf jeden fall ist es auch schon mein
gefühl 50 es von dieser sorte tour mal
kurz meine airport da hinten liegt
so konnte man jetzt ist ein deckel wenn
ich schlecht muss dir sind nicht dennoch
irgendwie ein deckel drauf aber ich
glaube da ist kein geld dabei
wahrscheinlich muss ich die erste
aufladen obwohl jetzt geht er jetzt
laden sind ja interessant also ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich sag jetzt auch
meine ehrliche meinung dazu der typ oder
die frau die sich das ausgedacht hat an
sich auf jeden fall eine coole idee
ich frag mich jetzt nur braun man das
also ich müsste damit jetzt wenig
anzufangen weil airport sind ja auch
eigentlich so leicht wenn man die kurz
in die tasche stecken kann
und wenn man dann dieses riesen case
dabei hat klar die sind immer geladen
aber ich habe auch hier mit eigentlich
kein problem weil die wirklich sehr sehr
lange halten und
hat man gleich so einen fetten
gegenstand in der tasche weil das ding
ist gar nicht mal so leicht ich weiß wie
ihr könnt ja mal eure meinung dazu in
die kommentare schreiben wie er das
findet und dann schaue ich mir das mal
an aber auch dass verlose ich sehr sehr
gerne auf dem münstermarkt deswegen
check das mal ab und abonnieren
natürlich auch den youtube-kanal ganz
wichtig so trotzdem kommt das jetzt
erstmal hier zurück in die verpackung
alles klar sollte dann würde ich sagen
wir haben noch genug sachen ich mache
jetzt mal auf 1 auf und ich glaube dann
ist das video auch schon 12 13 minuten
sagen das recht merklich für eine party
habe ich schon mal reingeschaut aber ich
kriege es trotzdem noch nicht ganz auf
so folgen
ach du heilige scheiße nicht dass das
video jetzt irgendwie erwachsen gestellt
wird wir haben hier ich weiß nicht ob
ich das einfach so sei ob und wo er
eigentlich schade wir haben hier einen
massiven cup er hat mir das denn
geschickt ich bin jetzt gerade haben
überlegen
ich glaub ich weiß es sogar weil die
dame tiffany halte glaube ich dir hab
mir sehr sehr viele mails geschickt mit
gutscheincode und sonstigen alles
natürlich und die hat auch schon dreimal
nachgefragt wann dieses video dann
endlich kommt zu ihrem ski nation cup
also tiffany schöne grüße wenn du das
verstehst
hier ist es ich weiß nur nicht ob ich
das produkt hier so zeigen kann darf er
wohl warum eigentlich mit sonst serie
ist halt und es ist auch komplett hier
drauf also eingestellt alles nur auf
chinesisch das heißt eventuell ist das
der absolute renner unter den chinesen
aber in deutschland gar nicht so beliebt
man weiß ja nicht schon wieder ein kabel
immer diese ganzen kabel
ach du heiliger strohsack ich weiß nicht
ob ich das jetzt hier thematisieren kann
also hier strecke nicht auf jeden fall
tiffany was essen wir denn dazu
geschickt ja ja ja ja das muss ich erst
mal laden bevor ich das und das und das
muss auch gut desinfiziert werden
ich wollte gerade zu sagen alter was
haben die chinesen denn für
große bildungs leute ich weiß nicht ob
ich das thematisieren kann für alle die
sich dafür interessieren ich verlinke
ich das sehr gerne in der video
beschreibung aber nachher wird das video
hier werbung und freundlich und das
wollen wir ja nicht
deswegen ist auf jeden fall ein nettes
porzellan accessoire was man sich mal
ganz ebenso auf den tischen kann sie
doch schön vorsichtig hier wieder rein
und dann würde ich sagen das war der
erste teil
wir haben noch einige sachen auf die ich
mich sehr freue vor allem die auch dass
ich bin echt mal gespannt was da drin
ist darum geht es dann im zweiten part
eventuell gibt es da noch einen dritten
wenn wir das bei atlas doch nach oben
aber hier in den kanal und wenn
irgendein produkt hast du dir gern zu
schicken wollt könnt ihr es sehr gerne
machen auf dem internat kommen wie es
auf jeden fall schon mal die drohne
verlost oder noch diese airports power
bank und meinetwegen auch diese
sexspielzeug hier das war's wie sonst
mal 19 wieder gibt es neues video bereit